hey guys this will essentially be a
continuation of the first abandoned
plotlines video since it sparked a lot
of discussion people have brought up
more points to go into which is why I'm
making this video some people had issues
that not every point was a plot line but
this series mainly points out everything
that was just forgotten whether it's big
or small but yeah here we go in the
beginning of season 3 the warlocks are
actively trying to kill Daenerys it's
set up that a warlock escapes and is
ominously peering over Danny and her
followers as if the Warlock will come
back but that whole assassination plot
line has dropped it was basically just
used as a scene to have a badass
introduction for sir Barristan Selmy
Sansa being married to Tyrion is a
pretty significant development in Game
of Thrones but they just drop it and
joke about it later on like officially
they should still be married because the
show never goes into a separation
process I mean I'd be down to get a
marriage story spin-off worse on
Centurion sort of their divorce via
trial by combat
also their marriage could have played
more of a conflict in season a given
they are paired together again instead
in the last two seasons they just laugh
it off and act like it never happened
she missed me terribly
so that whole plot line is just
abandoned after Cersei blows up the Sept
at the end of season six the faith of
the seven in that undercurrent plot in
King's Landing is dropped just because
she destroys the set that doesn't mean
the religion just goes away the majority
of people in King's Landing worship that
religion and they would be propelled
into chaos of the scepter suddenly
exploded by abandoning this minor plot
toward it makes the public of King's
Landing seem much more shallow this also
creates a big inconsistency because the
general public go from hating Cersei to
suddenly loving her in season eight they
are grateful for your protection
I guess the high sparrows in that whole
religion were just there so that starts
he could just blow them up it reminds me
of this mean great Sept go boom in
season six it's set up that the Lord of
Light and its followers will help Danny
and support her cause Daenerys Stormborn
is the one who was promised from the
fire she was reborn to remake the world
but outside of just spreading the word
in Mereen that's all they do
kinvaras stated this the Dragons will
purify non-believers by the thousands
burning their sins and flesh away so you
would also think they would be
interested in the Battle of King's
Landing and not just the Battle of
Winterfell but they don't bring them
back which is a shame throughout season
four it has set up that Danish dragons
are misbehaving and that she's losing
control of them this leads her to lock
them up and it would seem that it would
have a lasting impact even in season
five the Dragons seemed to hate her but
in season six when they break out they
seem to just be fine
Tyrion doesn't Akal them but they are
still imprisoned they disobey and the
whole notion that they're misbehaving
and there's no lasting consequences the
whole conflict just conveniently
disappears the faceless men's whole
plotline was basically being developed
throughout seasons two through six at
the end of it it just seems very
anti-climatic to the point of where it
just feels unresolved you're telling me
that the faceless men will allow are you
to kill the wave still a bunch of faces
and essentially justify their whole
order it seems that jaqen has some
affection towards her and is proud that
she ascended
but there are more faceless men that
would definitely want to hunt down aria
there's just no consequences for her
actions in this plotline although an guy
isn't technically a forgotten plotline
characters are still pieces of plot
lines and they contribute to the overall
story so in that sense they just
straight-up deleted anguy he was very
charismatic and likable but they didn't
bring him back in season six I don't
know what else to say he was just
abandoned speaking of Forgotten
characters
Salladhor saan was basically left behind
he was a pretty big asset when I came to
Davos is valued because he was a source
of ships they had a falling out after
the first time Davos lost his fleet
[Music]
but Davos got his fleet a second time
and we don't get to see an outcome to
that whole situation we don't know
whether Salladhor is mad or wants
vengeance because he's just left behind
as it was set up words were much more
common when it came to the free folk
after John goes to hardhome and saves
thousands of free folk we apparently
don't see any wargs there could have
been a very interesting development in
which brand meets an experience of warg
this war could a top brand torg into
anything about [ __ ] crows maybe even
larger animals like dragons intent so in
season seven they reintroduced the whole
idea that Dany may or may not be able to
have kids I can't have children who told
you that they weren't sure who murdered
my husband has it occurred to you she
might not have been a reliable source of
information and then they go into having
sex so the question remains can she have
children or can she not they just
dropped this whole question and I'm sure
they at least had sex more than once
this would have made for a much more
emotional climax if Danny was pregnant
and John had to still decide whether or
not to kill her for the good of the
realm but nope feels bad
so literally throughout the whole show
they keep setting up that this will be
the longest winter ever the peasant say
along sama means an even longer winter
color superstition but it seemingly
lasts like a couple of days or however
long the in show time was also after
they killed the night king it simle ends
the winter since it was snowing in
King's Landing in season seven and now
it's a desert so this just raises more
questions does the night can control the
seasons well there never be a winter
again I don't know just one turn in
general is abandoned I guess after so
much build-up when that stark dies both
Rickon and brand say they have dreams
about their father
and they go down to the Crypt as
anything until what's happening I saw
him one last night when I was sleeping
for bran this was later revealed that he
had these visions because he was a warg
but after this point they never tell us
why Rickon was having these somewhere
symptoms it's basically just left behind
and Rickon in general just gets heated
out of the story in season six when yara
confront his dani about wanting to start
an alliance a part of her terms in that
conversation was that she wanted the
Iron Islands to have their own
independence what if everyone starts
demanding that independence she's not
demanding she's asking after this point
I think David and Dan just forgot that
this even happens because in the ending
scene where everyone meets she doesn't
bring it up especially after Sansa
declares the north independent so in the
timeframe of one sentence spoken by
Jaime Dave and Dan managed to completely
ruin and abandon his entire character
arc and for every one of the million
people in that city innocent or
otherwise to be honest I never really
cared much for them innocent or
otherwise Jaime deep down was
sympathetic and this was shown when he
sacrifices his honor in order to save
King's Landing from the Mad King but in
season eight he for some reason says he
never cared for the public of King's
Landing so Jamie's whole arc from that
point on isn't validated and thus
abandoned
the iron bank in season seven bets
heavily in favor of Cersei winning and
they basically fund our whole operation
rest assured
yo grace you can count on the iron bank
support they obviously lose and the
question remains is what does the bank
do to get their money back the bank in
general just fades from existence and
nobody brings it up the line that Tywin
gives us that was very important was
that they are Bank always gets their
money back you can't run from them you
can't cheat them you can't sway them
with excuses if you have the money and
you don't want to crumble yourself you
pay it back but it's just unresolved
maybe a cool development is that the
bank hires the faceless men to get the
money back this would have tied the
faceless men back into the story and
Arya would have had to overcome one
final obstacle
instead of getting shorn into killing
the knight King for Jon Snow at the end
of season seven during the scene where
Dany and John are having sex
Tyrion looks at their room with a very
ominous and disapproving look this seems
to set up some sort of conflict for
Season eight and it's never brought up
again Taran is just delivering [ __ ] joke
right out of the gate instead of
exploring this development they set up
at the end of season seven so the reason
why I'm including Benjen stark is that
he was a very interesting piece of the
white Walker plotline his character in
essence is cool because he is half human
and half undead he is basically just
abandoned and he loses all depth by
becoming an ex machina all he does is
just save characters and is very clear
that David and Dan did not know what to
do with his character the horn Sam finds
at the fist of the first men is known as
the Horn of winter this is a plot point
in the books but it doesn't make sense
to introduce it in the show to just
abandon it I guess it's an easter egg
but they still set it up the horn
apparently has the power to bring down
the wall and it's a big point of
conflict for the books so the show
basically just abandons that whole plot
thread the only reason why I'm including
this plotline that's from the books is
because it actually makes an appearance
so I won't be including other plot lines
from the books that the show doesn't go
into Oberyn Martell was a pretty
integral character in season four and
everyone related to him was important as
well even his children known as the sand
snakes had
out of focus in season five so this
raises the question of what happened to
oberyn's other children here's a clip
where he mentions them for one of my
gutters we have several w88 surely they
would have more significance but David
and Dan just leave it alone it would
have been a pretty cool development if
the new Prince of Dorne was overand son
he could have potentially had an arc
avenging sword to Lannisters for killing
his father there's a couple moments that
hang up the idea that grand maester
pycelle is actually smarter than what he
is letting on these are your new
chambers little [ __ ] perhaps you don't
need much room do you you are no longer
hand of the king for your trouble
there's also this whole deleted scene
that reveals this fact am I the only one
to see through this performance there
are times when I have trouble believing
it myself and why do you bother so many
flowers my lord I don't want to be the
tallest or the brightest I only want to
remain in the garden but David and Dan
cut it out in the small plot line along
with it it's a shame because it makes pi
cells character much more interesting
and we get another Tywin scene which is
always a plus in season four what the
Hound is talking to Arya she asked him
what he wants to do my passage across
the Narrow Sea
why there's a self sword second Psalms
could be a good fit for me after he
comes back in season six he for some
reason decides to join the Brotherhood
without banners although he hates them
in season three they tried to kill him
and he often goes on about how much he
dislikes them Father sake will you shut
you know hope so it doesn't really make
much sense for him to go with her
Brotherhood instead of pursuing his own
personal goal and continuing down the
plotline that was set up in season
before Illyria was a pretty important
character in season one and they never
bring him back this somewhat make sense
but he doesn't come back to the story
for whatever reason when they're at his
palace in season 5 Varys and Illyrio
share the same goals and are working
together so story
it makes sense for him to make a
reappearance here it would have been
cool to see him reunite with nurse in
season 1 and he would have had some
value to the plotline throughout the
whole show John and ghosts have an
active relationship in the background
even in season 6 we have a very
wholesome moment where ghost is the last
friend in the room awaiting for John to
return in season 7 he doesn't even show
up and in season 8 he basically serves
no purpose at all for whatever reason
during the Battle of Winterfell ghost is
charging with Jorah Mormont who he
doesn't even know it would have been a
perfect opportunity for goes to come and
save John after he falls off of his
dragon instead of his pawn armor saving
him ghost would have actually had some
worth but all that happens is that he
gets pet once essentially towards the
later seasons there Horrell a shin ship
becomes very superficial and they just
delete ghost screentime to save money so
it's is really sad